I'm assistant sheriff Chris Jones and
I'm here to give you a few details on
last night's officer-involved shooting
before I get into those details I want
to give you a brief update on our
officer who was shot last night
sheriff Lombardo briefed last night
referenced our officer who was shot
while serving this community that
officer has identified as 29 year old
Shea mcclain us officer Michael anus has
been with LV MPD for four years and is
assigned to the convention center Area
Command his condition remains unchanged
from last night
he is still in grave condition on life
support
our thoughts and prayers are with him
and his family and we asked that yours
be as well reference the
officer-involved shooting ordinarily we
do not brief on officer involved
shootings until 72 hours later however
we're not in ordinary times we felt it
was important to come to you today and
give you a few details of the event last
night just after 11:00 p.m. a large
crowd had formed near the 300 block of
Las Vegas Boulevard south this is right
next to the federal courthouse on Las
Vegas Boulevard individuals within the
crowd or we coming rowdy and in order to
disperse was given by officers shortly
afterwards the majority of the crowd
dispersed traveling southbound on Las
Vegas Boulevard a few individuals did
remain one of those individuals has been
identified as Jorge Jorge Gomez
he's a 25 year old Hispanic male 180
pounds mr. Gomez was armed with two
Glock pistols and a third Glock pistol
that was inserted into a carbine
conversion kit
mr. Gomez began to walk toward officers
who were staged on the steps of the
federal courthouse clearly ignoring the
order to disperse one metro officer in
gate observed mr. Gomez and approached
and fired several rounds from a low
lethal shotgun this caused mr. Gomez to
turn northbound toward the other
officers who were trying to get to our
downed officer those officers were
threatened by mr. Gomez as he raised his
firearm toward them and they engaged him
firing several rounds and striking him
mr. Gomez was transported to an area
hospital where he was pronounced
deceased we will have our normal 72-hour
brief with more information but again we
felt it was necessary given the times
that we're in to come to the community
and give them information about this
event I'll show a couple of videos from
last night and then I'll take a few
questions
this is mr. Gomez
[Music]
obviously that was prior to the shooting
I'll take a couple of questions before I
turn it over to deputy chiefs Jim CBOC
at this point we believe he was alone
yes he is in Nevada Las Vegas Nevada
resident yes we fully anticipate more
demonstrations we fully anticipate more
protests Deputy Chief Jim CBOC will get
into the details of that and our
preparation for that so the answer to
your question short is yes but he'll get
into more details yes sir
that decision has been made we will have
national guardsmen with us tonight and
again chief CBOC will get into that if
there are no further questions
specifically about the officer-involved
shooting I'll turn it over to Deputy
Chief Jim C Bob thank you two completely
separate incidences not really thank you
and good afternoon my name is deputy
chief Jim CBOC I'm one of the two patrol
deputy Chiefs over our patrol division
I've worked these protests since they
started this past several days
let me first convey thanks to those in
the community our first responder
partners and all of those that have
reached out to us to show support for us
and the families of our injured officer
your thoughts and prayers are much
appreciated I also want to say that what
we're seeing is not indicative of the
community I policed over the last 27
years nor is it look like the community
that we all know and love and what we're
seeing is not representative of what we
all know Las Vegas to be I also want to
reiterate as sheriff Lombardo has said
from the beginning that these events
that spark these protests are
inconsistent with the training and
protocols of the lv MPD we are also
sickened by what we saw that sparked all
of this as an agency and from the patrol
division we respect everyone's
constitutional right to protest we are
here to support you and to keep you safe
as long as it's done lawfully
unfortunately that isn't what we've been
seen what we as an agency are
consistently seen over these last few
days is that these protests these
protests start
peacefully with all the good intentions
for significant change to spark the
conversation and hear what people
express what they want to say but as the
night goes on the good intended and
law-abiding people leave and those that
seek to break the law
stay behind these people are clearly not
here for peaceful purposes they are set
on damaging our community our businesses
and to cause harm to our officers and
the people in the area
I watched firsthand from the streets
from our command post how these
criminals are trying to leverage these
peaceful demonstrations to their
advantage over the few days we're seeing
these offenders become increasingly more
aggressive we're seeing them armed with
bats with axes with glass cutters so
they can cause damage to structures we
see them vandalize and throw bottles and
rocks and damaging objects in order to
cause harm and the rocks that they're
throwing they're not the kind that would
skip across a lake instead these are the
chunks of asphalt chunks of cinder block
that caused significant damage our harm
once their hurt and once they're thrown
and hit their target we've had over 25
officers injured from these types of
objects of the last several days I'm
going to ask them to play a few clips
that we've captured these are just small
representations of what we've been
seeing as you can see you can go and
play the video
this is them with the gas cans gonna
target one of our police vehicles oh
[ __ ] his logic shots above month six
what's up dude what's up people of this
tracker saying we're right next to you
what's up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
those are some of the examples of what
my officers are trying to contain bring
to a peaceful resolution and when
they're committing crimes like that we
will be taking them to jail we have been
taken in the jail as their aggression
changes our resolve only becomes that
much more clear we are simply not going
to tolerate this kind of unlawful
behavior we will arrest you and you will
go to jail and lastly I want to remind
all of those that seek to lawfully
protest to make change in our community
please reach out to us meet with us
Sheriff Lombardo has demonstrated a
willingness to always work with our
community he has provided transparency
and all we do we listen to our community
our use of force policy was created in
conjunction with community members we
recently trained all of our department
on the new policy that included way
before these incidents that happen that
includes putting people in a recovery
position as soon as possible after an
arrest the goal of LV MPD is to continue
to grow and partner with our community
finally I just asked for the public to
please continue to pray for our officer
and all that is going on in our
community thank you
I don't have enough information to
answer that the information I have seen
is the majority are still local yes we
still have officers policing our
community keeping us safe we've been
bringing in officers extra on overtime
we've had great partnerships with
Henderson and North Las Vegas city
Marshalls Knight County NHP parole and
probation all of our partners are coming
together to keep Southern Nevada safe
this impacts all of our officers but it
also reminds our it reminds everyone of
the dangers of our job it reminds
everyone that the commitment that these
officers these men and women take every
day to serve our community and it does
strengthen their resolve to want to do
the best that they can and we have
tremendous leadership here at this
department that continues to provide the
support the wellness services to our
officers and to their families and we
are checking the pulse of the morale
every single day to make sure our
officers are ready and prepared before
they hit the streets
we allowed these protests to occur we
allow them to stay lawfully on the
sidewalks sometimes when it gets too big
they have to go onto the streets last
night for example we made room for them
we tried to block traffic we even moved
officers back away so the protester
could go through but a contingent
remained behind as I said last night the
crowd was probably around 3,000 and the
majority of them started marching
peacefully back but a good number at say
approximately 3 to 500 stayed behind and
then they began to do actions such as
you saw there yes what I'll speak to
here locally is we did provide our
officers with protective equipment
because of the items that were being
thrown if you notice on the first day a
lot of our officers were not wearing
that gear and we did have a lot of
officers injured and so again we give
the people the opportunity to do their
constitute constitutionally protected
activity lawfully and when they're not
we provide them an opportunity to stop
we give them a dispersal order and we
ask them to move on and if not then we
have to take the appropriate action yes
in the bank
I'm sorry I didn't hear the first party
question our officer safety is always at
the utmost every day we tried to learn
lessons learned from the night before on
the different tactics that are being
employed and we tried to do different
tactics in response to keep our officers
safe the community safe and so we can
have a peaceful night very few just one
prior of one narcotics prior so thank
you again for coming out we'll have more
information for you and then coming days
thank